i was hoping to get your thoughts on
bullying if your child is being bullied
what would you tell him or her
this is i guess it's a little bit of a
softball for me
to throw this question out because you
know what i'm going to say get your kid
a jiu jitsu
you can jujitsu immediately um get them
in there
and let them start to learn what it's
like
to deal with people physically and it
will build up their confidence
and it won't be a false confidence it'll
be a real confidence because they will
know how to handle themselves
they will have people that are trying to
take them down to the ground and trying
to choke them and they will learn to
stop that from happening and they will
learn to do it to other people
when warranted yeah
so that's how you prevent
bullying in my opinion you also get him
to start doing pull-ups push-ups dips
you get him to do a little bit of boxing
maybe even a little muay thai i'll tell
you at our gym
over the years we've probably had
half a dozen kids that have come in
specifically
because they were getting bullied at
school and every one of those cases
within three months four months maybe
six months at the outset
the parents are coming to me and saying
he's not getting bullied anymore
and there sometimes there's that that
that
incident where i've had a few students
that have
you know these are kids are you know 10
years old getting picked on getting
picked on getting picked on
and all of a sudden they start training
jiu jitsu and then one day they choke
out the bully
and they never get picked on again and
they're confident and they're not jerks
about it they become defenders because
they know what it's like to be bullied
so they don't like to see other people
get bullied
so i would say you know get your kids
into jiu jitsu if they're getting
bullied
and it will not only teach them to
prevent themselves from being bullied
it will prevent them from becoming a
bully yeah
because they'll recognize what it's like
and what the power of physical
intimidation is
yeah and they will not like it yeah yeah
and and i would say would help them not
become a bully because a lot of stuff
that goes on at home
you know everyone's different everyone's
family is different but a lot of times
bullies
people kids that become bullies they're
bullied at home
so being a bully is just a result of
something
else you know so yeah jiu-jitsu because
it helps your
your confidence and your security as a
kid so you will feel
less insecure if you're an insecure kid
so that alone is really powerful
even if you are prone to becoming a
bully and
this is kind of this is kind of well
known i think it's pretty well known
that
usually when you're bullied like when
someone's bullying someone else even
adults
it's not necessarily about beating them
up and picking on them beating them up
it's
it's less about the physical part of it
and more about just the mental
power it's the power trip so when you
learn jiu jitsu and
man i'm telling you i i wasn't really
bullied or nothing like that
but when you start to know jiu-jitsu you
have it in your head it's
it's almost like you can't help but just
radiate that kind of secure
confidence so when if you like if you're
if you roll in and you know jujitsu now
and a bully tries to bully you
he will gather immediately and there's
programs like specific programs
having to do with jiu-jitsu you know
bully proof and all these stuff and just
generally speaking you learn this in jiu
jitsu
where you just basically you just stand
your ground
and you basically you can there's all
these different ways to do it but you
call out the bully like are you
are you trying to fight me right now and
just standing up to him
will usually stop the bullying because
if they bully you and you're like oh
oh and i'll tell you even though a
majority of the bullying is
verbal or mental or psychological yeah
it's all on the premise all the bullying
is
built on the premise most of the time
that i can physically beat you up so
therefore you can't do anything yeah
occasionally you'll get some
young scrappy little loudmouth kid that
just bullies people just on the fact
that they just don't care right
right that's a rare that's a rare breed
most bullies
they feel like they can physically win
and therefore they can mentally abuse
people
yeah and once that once the once the
victim
realizes you know what i can actually
take this person out the whole dynamic
changes
yeah yeah and just that that first stage
of standing up to him
just even verbally that's in the bully's
mind that's a little indicator
you sh i can't i'm only this guy but
some beliefs they might be like hey
size advantage this guy's just feeling a
little triumphant today
and he's going to try to stand up to me
and then they'll they'll push it
and then when you know the jiu jitsu
yeah it man you can deal with bullies
really easy as a kid
double leg take down mount yeah
slap to the faces man make a joke i wish
i knew it when
when i was a little kid it teaches you
perfectly where to be and where not to
be where you just control the fight
okay it can be big and oh man oh i wish
i started when i
wish he was around when i was young